EVAN RAPOPORT: Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming today.
We are going to go over
the Views from Everywhere,
how we're bringing the world's
largest photo library to you,
our developers, and to
those of you who have not
stayed at the World Cup to
watch the last few minutes.
So thank you for coming.
I'm Evan Rapoport.
I'm a product manager on the
Street View in Google Maps
team.
And this is Luc Vincent,
engineering director
for Street View and
trekker extraordinaire.
[LAUGHTER]
So I used to live in Hawaii,
and we had this great tradition
back here that I'm trying
to bring everywhere I go,
especially when it's cold--
even though it's summer here
in San Francisco.
And that was where as a
speaker, I would say "Aloha,"
and the entire room
would scream back
"Aloha" with this
vigor that made
you feel like it
was 80 degrees out.
And kids did this really well.
I used to teach in schools,
and everyone really enjoyed it,
and it was a lot of fun.
So we're going to
do it right now,
and we're going to try to make
sure it feels a little warm
here in San Francisco.
So, aloha!
AUDIENCE: Aloha.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Wonderful.
Ah, every time, I love it.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate that.
So today this is what
we're going to go over.
We're going to talk about how
over the last several years,
we've been creating the world's
largest geolocated photo
library through our efforts
in Street View in Google Maps.
We're going to talk about
how you can add your imagery,
just in case we've missed places
that you really care about.
And then we're going
to talk about how
you can access all this
data, including your own,
using our APIs and our viewers,
all at Google-scale serving.
So why are we doing this?
I hate to be cheesy,
but it's kind of-- it's
this beautiful world
out there, and we really
want to help you explore it.
We really feel, at
the Google Maps team,
that it's our opportunity,
and it's actually
almost are our
mandate, to make sure
that you have better real-world
experiences as you travel,
as you make local decisions,
as you go somewhere
on the weekend.
And so we really want
to be the team that
can help you have better
experiences in the real world.
And we care so
much about photos--
as you can tell by one of
the world's largest cameras
sitting next to me-- that we
believe photos can inspire us.
We see photos like this and it
says, hey, I want to go there.
Where is that?
Who hasn't seen that in
a post on social media?
Where was that photo?
I want to go there.
This happens to be the
Sydney Harbour Bridge,
and I wouldn't suggest
hiking to the top
during a lightning storm.
But these are the kind of
things that inspire us.
We see a photo like this and
we say, hey, to your family,
let's go on a safari.
Let's travel the world.
Photos have this
opportunity to inspire us.
And when they're on maps, it
tells us exactly where they are
and where we can go.
And we're really
excited about this.
So without further ado,
I'd like to pass it over
to Luc to talk about what we've
been doing with Street View
to bring you imagery
all over the world.
LUC VINCENT: Thanks, Evan.
This is me in this picture
wearing this contraption,
and this is me wearing
it right now live.
I love wearing this thing.
We'll tell you more
about it later.
What is our mission
in this team?
We would like to bring
imagery to our users,
our billions of
users, everywhere.
And we want to collect it,
organize it, make it useful.
Our guiding principle really
is to be comprehensive,
be everywhere, be useful,
obviously, and be accurate.
Imagery that we collect
around the world
should be well
geolocated in order
to be useful in our products.
So this is our mission.
And I will tell you a little bit
about how we're going about it
and how we want make it
useful not just to our users
but to developers worldwide.
So how do we go about
collecting this imagery?
Well, as you probably
well know, we
have already satellite
imagery that we've
had in our products
for about a decade.
And this imagery is,
in fact, very accurate.
Even the clouds are accurate.
If you use the new Google Maps,
the cloud cover is real-time.
Zooming in further,
we have also collected
and we are actively pursuing
collection of aerial imagery
around the world.
And we use this oblique
imagery to create 3D cities, so
3D models of urban
areas around the world.
We have hundreds of them now,
also making a map more useful.
You can see here
one of the stadiums
we collected in Brazil
for the World Cup.
We have all of them, I believe,
collected in 3D [INAUDIBLE].
And zooming even further, you
will see a familiar area here,
the Bay Area.
And in the new
Google Maps, we have
made imagery much
more prominent.
We have what we call
the runway, which
is this bar of pictures at the
bottom, which shows you imagery
that's most relevant
to your current view.
Imagery that's meant to be
useful and representative
of what you're
interested in looking at.
We have imagery,
as you may notice,
from-- we have
photos from users.
Photo spheres--
and I will tell you
more about photo
spheres in a minute.
We also have a lot
of street imagery.
Street View remains the largest
corpus of geolocated photos
that we have in
our maps, and it's
something we've been working
on for almost a decade.
So speaking of Street View,
let me tell you a little bit
about how we got started
with this crazy mission, what
we're doing about it
today, and then we'll
talk about our sort of expanding
community efforts in the Street
View space.
So Street View started
actually over a decade ago.
It was an idea by
our CEO, Larry Page,
who felt really that
street-level imagery should
be useful to our users.
And he really wanted
to make [INAUDIBLE]
accessible and useful.
So he himself collected imagery
using a camcorder in the Bay
Area and used the
footage he collected
to bootstrap research, early on
at Stanford University and then
at Google.
And in 2005, a group of
googlers, which I was part of,
decided it was really time
to do something about this
and to make this real.
So we developed a bunch of
computer visual algorithms
and built a platform
to collect imagery.
You see here in 2006,
we built these very
large and crazy-looking vans
full of cameras and equipment,
which we sort of took around
the US-- in the Bay Area,
in particular-- and
collected imagery.
Enough imagery, and we were
able to process it enough,
to actually launch a product.
We launched Street View
in 2007 in Google Maps
in first five cities.
And there was so much
interest and sort of traffic,
we couldn't believe it.
So we thought we had
something useful,
and so we worked hard to grow
this product and scale it.
So you see here, over the
course of 2007 through 2008,
we actually expanded
our coverage in the US.
This is coverage
expanding rapidly here.
And then we essentially
expanded the whole product
around the world,
and we're still
busy doing this right now.
In the process of
doing this, we've
hit just about any kind
of issue you may imagine.
Unique problems
happened at scale.
For example, this one.
This is co collected imagery
in the Amazon, in Brazil,
and frogs jumping on the camera.
How many of you
here, photographers,
have had frogs jump
on your camera?
Not very many, right?
So we've had that.
We've had other encounters
with other animals,
like donkeys in some parts
of the world, what have you.
So anything can happen,
and has happened.
So we've learned in the process.
We've refined our processes.
We've refined our algorithm.
We've refined our cars,
our approach to it.
And you know, today
we're very proud to have
build a really global platform
for imagery collection.
This is our latest car.
You've probably
seen them roaming
the Bay Area and
wherever you live.
We have them in lots of places,
and we're busy expanding.
In fact, we have realized,
not that long ago,
that you couldn't just do this
only with cars, obviously.
The most beautiful
parts of the world
are not accessible by cars.
Imagine castles, parks, museums.
So we've built a
variety of platforms
derived from the
Street View car.
You see we have
put it on a boat.
We have designed
this tricycle that
can be mounted on various
other parts, like on a train,
or it can be used by itself,
like here at Stonehenge.
We have also a snowmobile.
And we even have a partner
called the Catlin Seaview
Survey that's built a rig that
goes underwater to capture
coral reefs, and
they use our platform
to publish the imagery.
We started launching
these special collections
of unique heritage
sites a few years ago,
and when we launched
Pompeii-- as you see here
on the left in this picture--
the Italian heritage
authorities actually
told us they
had noticed an increase
in foot traffic
to Pompeii, 25% increase.
And we've noticed similar
kind of increased traffic
in some museums.
So we take this as
sort of evidence
that our imagery is not
just for couch potatoes.
It's imagery that not just
lets you travel virtually,
but inspires you to travel
physically and go to places
and explore the world.
So we're very happy about this.
So more recently, we've
built this Trekker, which
I'm currently wearing,
and we've taken it also
to lots of places
where you can't really
go other than by foot.
Here you see we've had a group
of googlers go to the Galapagos
to capture a few of the
unique sights there.
All this imagery is up in Maps.
And also was lucky enough to
go be part of the Grand Canyon
rafting trip, where we took
these trekkers on two rafts
and captured the entire
length of the Grand Canyon.
And the imagery is now
live in Street View
as well, on Google Maps.
And this was really my
best business trip ever.
So it's really imagery
that not everybody
would be able to
capture themselves.
So we like to bring it to people
who couldn't travel there.
So where are we now?
Here's our status.
We have driven--
we have launched
imagery in about 56
countries-- give and take,
because some countries
don't necessarily count.
We have over five
million miles live,
and that's about 20
times the descent
from the Earth to the moon,
to give you a reference.
We have imagery on
all seven continents.
So we have been busy,
and we've learned a lot.
But in fact, we have
even more than that,
because we recently,
a few months ago,
launched what we call Street
View Time Machine, which
doesn't just let you explore a
place by moving geographically,
but lets you explore in time.
So we added the fourth
dimension, really,
to Street View and we help tell
the story of a place over time.
If you go in Street View,
you will find lots of places
in Asia, where there's
frenetic construction.
You will see the story of
construction over time.
And you can explore at each sort
of time slice geographically,
as well.
Sometimes, sadly, this is
also a story of destruction,
like here in Japan,
following the earthquake.
We have, actually,
imagery before and after.
In fact, in many cases,
we found that Street View
is the only photographic record
of places before disaster,
which is amazing to us.
However-- so we
have done all this.
We have built this
amazing platform.
We have millions
of miles of imagery
captured in lots of countries.
But we still need help.
Why?
Why is that so?
Well, turns out if you really
wanted to capture imagery
everywhere, you would
need trillions of images.
We only have billions,
so we have a ways to go.
In addition, we can't just
take our cars and sort
of drive everywhere
all the time, right?
We can't take our Trekkers
and sort of go everywhere.
We need some help.
We can't do it without your
community involvement, right?
And this is where I
think you guys fit in.
Not only can you help us by
building amazing apps that
can actually make the
imagery more useful to more
people in more contexts,
as Evan will talk about,
but you can also help by
encouraging more people
to go and help collect
imagery, in ways that Evan will
talk about, and make it useful
in the content of these apps.
So without further ado,
I'll pass it over to Evan,
who will talk
about these efforts
and how we are hoping
to engage everybody.
Evan.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Thanks, Luc.
All right.
So I'm really excited today
to talk to you about ways
in which you can create Street
View-like experiences yourself
and then bring them into your
apps with your own imagery
or with ours.
So we find from user surveys
that people really just like
using Street View to
know where they're
going, to see it in advance.
This is one of the top
uses that we see for it.
And what more
appropriate way to do it
than this example of Walgreen's
using the Android Maps API,
to make sure that you know
what their store looks
like as you're driving there?
It's pretty straightforward, but
it works exactly as promised.
When you're on your way
there to Walgreen's, they've
made sure that you know
what the place looks like.
So who here has planned a
running route or a biking route
or a hiking route
using Street View?
All right, I see a
good number of hands.
So thanks to apps
like Runtastic--
which you can see out
there on the floor,
if you want to go
talk to them-- they're
using the Android Maps API to
integrate Street View directly
into their app so
you can understand
what your running route
is going to look like.
Is it a place
that's safe to run?
Is it a lot of elevation?
Things like that.
You can get a really
good idea of the place
and plan it, right
there in Runtastic.
OK, who's ever used Street
View while you were running?
Not expecting too
many hands here.
Good.
OK, thanks to Icon
Fitness, they've
built this treadmill that
allows you to sort of virtually
run through Street View as
you're on the treadmill.
It syncs to the speed
you go, and you probably
could see how this
would be a lot of fun,
especially if you're in a sweaty
gym or a basement or something
like that.
Using the JavaScript
Maps API they
built this Street View viewer
that syncs to your speed.
And so now, unless you're
some crazy, crazy runner,
I don't think you're going to
run out of Street View to see.
As Luc mentioned, we
have five million miles.
So start your running right now.
Speaking of sort of these
virtual experiences,
who here is excited
about Cardboard?
All right.
I expected lots of hands there.
So I love Cardboard.
I'm really, really
excited about what
this is going to do to
bring virtual reality-type
experiences to everybody.
All of the Street View data
that we're talking about here
is available to you
to use in Cardboard.
So if you head over
to g.co/cardboard,
you can learn more about that.
Additionally,
we're going to talk
about photo spheres and
user-contributed panoramas,
and how you can immediately
capture your own imagery
with Android, 360 panoramas,
and then put them directly
into your Cardboard apps.
So those of you who have been
playing around with it, you
probably see a little thing
called Photo Sphere right there
in your Cardboard UI.
That's a great way
and a great example
to show how you could bring
photo spheres into Cardboard.
So I'm really
excited to see what
you're going to do with this.
Let's see what you can do.
So if we don't have
imagery where you want it,
it doesn't matter how
much imagery we have.
And so we've really wanted
to open up our platforms
to everyone, so I'm going to
talk about a few of those.
The first is the
Trekker Loan program.
As Luc is showing here,
this is the Trekker
that we have been sharing with
partners, at no cost to them,
to go where they want to go.
In the past with Street
View, it was always us going.
So our employees would go on
these wonderful business trips
and collect spots, and if
it was raining that day,
that sucked for us.
That was the day we
had film permits.
With this program, we've
partnered with organizations
like travel authorities
and nonprofits
and educational groups, and been
sending our Trekkers to them,
and they go where they want
to go when they want to go.
Because who knows
these places better
than the people who actually
live and love these locations?
And so our first
partner we announced
last year was the Hawaii
Visitors and Conventions
Bureau.
And they went and they hiked
the most of the Big Island
and all of the
hiking trails there,
and now they're doing
the same thing on Oahu.
Here's an example
of imagery that they
collected in Volcanoes
National Park.
You can now walk through
an active volcano virtually
in Street View.
Again, they've done this
all at no cost to them.
We gave them the Trekker.
We gave them a bunch
of FedEx envelopes.
They just mailed
disks back to us.
And we just keep it
going, and they just
keep going on trekking.
It's a really wonderful
program, and if you
work with any travel
groups or anyone who
would be interested
in the Trekker,
I encourage you to
go check that out.
Here's a great
example of closing
the loop of how the Hawaii
Visitors and Conventions
Bureau launched all this data
directly in their website,
using the JavaScript Maps API,
so that when you're planning
your trip on gohawaii.com, you
can actually see this Trekker
imagery.
So again, they
collected it, they
went where they wanted to
go, and they published it.
We host it and we serve it,
and it's available to them
through the API.
It's a really great
way to plan your trip.
So if you're interested,
there's the URL, g.co/trekker.
Sign up.
Again, we're looking
for people that
are like tourism groups,
non-profits, companies--
people that could get film
permits for the locations
that they want to go.
We're really excited to
talk to you more about that.
If you have indoor places
that you care a lot about,
Trekker doesn't really
work too well indoors.
And so we have a program
called Google Business View.
What this does is lets
you go into restaurants
and small businesses and hotels
and things like that, all
around the world, and with
trusted photographers who we've
worked with, they can go
into these businesses.
They sell their services and
they create virtual tours
for these restaurants
and businesses.
We've seen a huge amount of
success with this program.
People are really
excited about it.
And we've been growing this
program really, really quickly.
So again, all of this
data goes into Google Maps
and becomes available to you
developers as part of our APIs.
Additionally, the imagery is
really high-quality and very,
very consistent, because these
are trusted partners or trusted
photographers.
And so we've made
it very prominent,
right there in Google Maps.
So you'll see a See Inside
label on some of this imagery,
and you can just click right
in and go right into that.
And it's also really
prominent on Google Search.
So if you want this
beautiful search listing,
this is a great way for your
clients, for your businesses,
to ensure that you have this
really beautiful listing there.
And the click-through
rate is very, very high
on that imagery, as
you might imagine.
Here's the URL where you can
find out more about this.
Again, this talk is
all being recorded.
You could go back
to those later.
But just search for
Google Business View.
All right.
So who knows Photo Sphere?
I expected this audience would
be a big round of applause.
Come on.
No, just kidding.
LUC VINCENT: Yay, Photo Sphere.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Woo-hoo!
I love Photo Sphere.
I spin in circles all the
time, capturing photo spheres.
You can ask my wife.
So Photo Sphere started
off a couple years
ago with the Android team,
where we launched on the Nexus 4
and we created this way to make
Street View-like imagery as
easy as possible.
You just simply
held up your phone
and spun around
and captured 360s,
just like you've
seen in Street View.
We've since grown a lot more.
And just recently, we announced
the Google Camera app,
available for KitKat.
Who's got the Google Camera app?
All right.
Everyone should get
the Google Camera app.
It's really, really cool, and
if that's not the sexiest URL--
g.co/camera-- I
don't know what is.
So go get that app.
And in that, you can create
50-megapixel photo spheres.
Street View is
about 75 megapixels,
so we're getting up
there with Photo Sphere.
Again, all of this done
right there with your phone.
We've built a viewer for photo
spheres into Play Services.
So as Sundar
mentioned yesterday,
well over 90% of users
can get these viewers
and can see photo spheres.
And there's an API for you to
hook up to that in your app.
And we've created
an open metadata
standard for Photo Sphere.
We've seen that panoramas
were just not growing
at the rate in the world
that we knew that they could,
and so we created an open
standard, which I'll talk about
in a minute.
So 50 megapixels, that's big.
But I just want to give you
a really clear understanding.
So that's the photo
sphere, and there's
the zoom-in of the detail that
you can get with these images.
Again, all this captured with
my Nexus 5, no post processing
or anything like that.
Uh, I'm from Hawaii.
Come on, I had to show a
little bit of eye candy.
This is a morning in Waikiki.
I captured this photo sphere.
This is now available
on Google Maps.
And if you come down to Mountain
View and you're on our campus
there at Google, you can see
some amazing places like this.
Again, Photo Sphere
can work well indoors.
Just a little bit of practice
keeping the phone close to you,
and we can create these really
amazing indoor panoramas
and experiences that you can
use in your apps and published
maps.
So I mentioned the
metadata standard.
This is a really
important thing for us,
and it's been a huge success.
We didn't want this to just
be a closed thing, where
photo sphere was something that
only Google Apps can create,
so we made it open.
And as a result, we've
seen some of the world's
top panoramic stitching
softwares adopt this standard.
So when you save out an
image from this software,
it'll have the photo
sphere metadata in this.
It uses Adobe's XMP, which
is kind of similar to Exif,
but it's XML-based and it's
very easy to understand.
Its human-readable.
And you can use
this in your images,
and that way they'll work
on Google+, on Google Maps,
on Street View on Android, on
all the Google products that
support it.
So we've also seen the
one click 360 cameras,
like the Ricoh Theta if
anyone has seen Ricoh Theta.
Who's seen Ricoh Theta?
I'm just kind of curious.
All right, this is a
really cool little device.
I see even one over there.
You hold this up.
You take a picture.
It has two fish-eye
lenses and it
captures the entire
scene in one click.
It's a really,
really cool device.
And it uses the Photo
Sphere metadata,
so you can add those
directly to Google Maps.
And I run around like this with
these over my head and capture
pictures while my
wife goes like this.
And then there's a number
of these devices coming out
on Kickstarter soon, or
that are on Kickstarter,
that you may have seen, that
are launching this year.
These are, again,
one-click 360 cameras
that are going to create
Street View experiences
and have used the Photo
Sphere metadata standard.
So really exciting
year for all of us
that are excited about 360s.
We also had a great
collaboration with the Auto
Awesome team in Google+.
So if you don't know how to
add metadata into JPEGs--
and let's face it, most of
us don't-- just upload these
images to Google+.
It recognizes that
it's a 2x1 panorama.
It notices that the edges are
kind of matching each other.
And it'll Auto Awesome and give
you back a copy of your image
with the metadata in it,
that you can immediately put
into Google Maps or
share on Google+.
So let's talk a little bit
about how we can actually
get Photo Sphere
into your products.
I want to dive into
some code really quick,
so I'll talk about how
to actually publish
to Maps in a minute.
But let's talk about how to
actually just get these in.
So iframe, not really
that much code.
That's pretty simple.
But I had to start
somewhere, right?
So we have an embeddable viewer.
If you go to Views, which
is a product I'll talk about
in a minute, you can simply copy
and paste this HTML snippet,
put it right into your
apps or your products,
and you'll be able to view
photo spheres right there.
It uses the same Street
View viewer that we have,
so it's very robust.
And we have no usage
limits for this.
You can customize your
presentation of the image.
You can tweak
parameters and all that.
And it's a really
great and easy way
to put photo spheres
into your websites.
All right, a little bit of code.
I wish I could make it
more complicated for you,
but it's just not complicated.
So it's very, very simple.
If you're familiar with the
JavaScript API for Maps,
there is a Street
View object in there.
And usually you just set
the latitude and longitude
as to where you want
the Street View panorama
and we give you the nearest one.
Well, in the case
of Photo Sphere,
you actually know the
exact image that you want.
And so there's a
property called pano,
and you just tell
it the panorama ID
that you're interested in--
which that iframe code that I
just showed you about has
in it, so you can just
copy and paste those out.
And then we'll give you
back your photo sphere
directly there.
It's really just that easy.
There's not much more to say.
You could build a gallery
with Photo Sphere,
using this very, very easily.
On Android, it's
again the same thing.
Instead of specifying
a lat/long,
you see I have a pano ID
field or a variable there.
That's all you do.
So specify that pano,
and we'll give you
back that image instead of
the nearest Street View one.
So very, very easy
for you to go,
with Android, capturing
panoramas and then putting them
directly back into
your Android app
without even having to go to a
desktop, if you don't want to.
So I mentioned Views.
Views is a community we created
to make this easier and easier
for you to publish
panoramas to the web
and create your Street
View experiences.
So g.co/views, you
can go check that out.
And this is a place
that brings together
all of our great Street
View special collections
and our Trekker collections,
but then also content from you.
And then that content
gets shown on Google Maps.
So it's really exciting for us
that when you look at a place
here, like Half Dome, and
you see all the Street View
paths winding their
way through Yosemite,
the leftmost image there,
the top-ranked image,
actually happens to be from a
user, and it's a photo sphere.
You'll see only one
Street View panorama
on this but lots of
user-contributed content.
We've made this content
really, really highly promoted
because we think it's
the most interesting
and the most relevant.
As Luc mentioned, the most
amazing things in the world
usually aren't
seen from the road,
and so you're able to
contribute these images.
And how cool is it to
have the canonical view
of Half Dome in Google
Maps be your image?
I think that's just a
really neat experience,
as a photographer, I guess.
So back to Views.
Views is a place that,
like Google Maps,
lets you browse over an area
that you're interested in
and see all the
top-ranked imagery there.
So we're looking
at Las Vegas here
because I was recently
there for a talk.
And all the images
on the right really
just do match up
to the top spots
that you would see
around Las Vegas.
We also have a Top Photographers
list at the top of the site,
so you can find
all the people who
are really active contributors.
And hey, if you're looking to
hire a photographer in a spot,
this is a great way to find
some photographers, too.
In Views, we also give
you a profile page,
so sort of like a gallery
of your own imagery.
And I really love this.
This is mine, and it
just has all the images
that I've been capturing
over the last year or so.
I travel quite a bit
for work, and so you'll
see a lot of red dots on my map.
This is basically
showcasing my travels.
And I use this
pretty regularly when
friends ask me, like, what
should I do in Hawaii?
Or what hike should
I do this weekend?
I actually find the spots
there and then I send that off,
and I say, great, these
are all the photos spheres
that I've taken in that spot.
These would be my
recommendations of places
that you should see.
It's really helpful.
I'm sure you could
find ways to think
of how this would be relevant
to your business or your users.
But we know that Photo Sphere
isn't fully Street View yet,
right?
It's about connected
experiences, not
singular one-panorama images.
And so last year in December,
we announced a feature
that lets you take a bunch
of dots and connect them,
because it's really
just that easy.
So you just dive into
this experience here
and you connect the dots.
That's what Street View is.
It's connecting the dots.
You fix the locations
a little bit.
You rotate the images
if their compass heading
wasn't quite on.
And then you go ahead
and you publish that.
It's basically from
your phone to this tool,
and then right back
out to Street View.
It's a very, very
quick and easy process.
You could do the Moscone
Center by the end of the day,
if you really wanted to.
And if you do, come let me know.
I'll get you a T-shirt.
So everyone does things
for t-shirts, it seems.
So we're really excited
about this, and as a result,
we've seen some amazing things
coming in from our users.
This is a great
user up in Montreal
who went out in
the freezing cold
and documented his local
park with 400 panoramas
in the freezing cold--
as his hands were
like, you know, barely kind
of able to open anymore--
and documented the entire
park and published it
to Google Maps.
And now this experience
is there for all of you
to use in your apps,
to explore or to look.
And it's just this
pride in the place
that you live that really drove
him to go out and do that.
So I challenge you to go
out there and find places
that you care about and
document those, too.
So we've spoken a lot
about how to do things,
and we've talked a lot about
why you would do it-- you know,
to inspire people to
travel and to help
them make good decisions.
So I also want to talk a little
bit strategically about some
of the benefits that this has
for you and for your clients.
So who puts photos
on social media?
I don't even need to see hands.
That's probably everybody.
So we all put photos
up there, and then we
know that everyone's going
to see it right now, right?
You publish this photo,
you get lots of engagement
immediately over a few
minutes, maybe a few hours--
maybe even a few days,
if you're really popular.
When you put photos
on Google Maps,
people are not going
to see it immediately
at this really,
really high rate.
What they're in
fact going to see
is when it's relevant
to them-- when they're
planning trips, when they're
thinking about travel, when
they're dreaming of
their next vacation.
And so if that's
important to you,
this is exactly what you
need to be thinking about.
This is where people
go to plan these trips.
They probably don't go look
at a social media channel
to think about a vacation.
And even the most beautiful
photo you see right there
might not be actually
the right time for them
to be thinking about a trip.
And so I like to
think of it this way.
This is a graph--
there's no numbers on it,
it's a concept-- of
total views over time,
of thinking about how many
views your photo is going
to get over time and
what kind of engagement
you're going to expect.
In social media, again, you
get these great spikes and this
is a really amazing way to get
your message out right now.
Definitely, do that.
It's really, really valuable.
But what we've seen, and as
the data starts to show--
and I'll show you some data
in a minute-- over time
you're going to get far more
engagement for relevant places
and interesting places
when you publish
content in a
maps-based environment.
Because again, it's
constantly relevant to people
over and over and over
again throughout time,
as long as that
place continues to be
a place that people
are looking at.
Again, Google Maps
has a billion users.
A billion users are going
to see these places.
And so I'm suspecting this
is a skeptical audience that
wants some data, so let's
show a little bit of data
just to show how
this has been working
in the wild for
some of our users.
So here's a user, really
talented panoramic photographer
who travels the world.
And look at the
type of engagement
that he's getting here.
In just less than a year, he's
gotten almost six million views
of the content that he's
published via Google Maps.
But what's even more interesting
is that he only has a few
hundred followers in
his Google+ Circles.
He's not a celebrity.
He's just an amazing
photographer.
And his work is getting out
there and it's helping people.
Think of that six
million not just as
six million views, but
six million opportunities
to inspire someone
to go to a spot
or to virtually explore a place.
He's getting all
this engagement not
through social media strategies
or marketing strategies
or anything like that,
but just by traveling
to interesting
places and publishing
really useful imagery.
Here's another example.
This is an agency
down in Australia
that's been traveling
the world, and they
do lots of panoramic
photography.
They do development
work for clients.
And in just three months-- they
came to me a couple months ago
and asked what to do,
and I just said, well,
publish your imagery.
In just three months,
they've built up
over three million
views on their content.
They have amazing content.
It's really, really beautiful.
And you can see that, again,
they have under 100 followers
in their Google+ Circles.
This is just really
a type of engagement
that we don't tend
to think about,
but they're publishing
content in places
that matter, in places
that people really look at.
And their tour of
the Eiffel Tower
is just one of the most
beautiful ones I've ever seen.
So again, really, really
good success story here.
So to get started with
Views, g.co/views.
We've been at this for a while.
We have some really, really
exciting announcements
coming up in the next few months
that I can't talk about today.
But trust me, you want to follow
along and see what we're doing.
It's going to be a really
fun year for Views.
All right.
So to summarize,
today what we've
shown you is how we've been
collecting the world's largest
geolocated photo library
using Street View and all
of our different
products, like Trekker.
But most importantly,
I think, for this group
is that when we don't have the
places that you care about,
we've enabled you to collect the
imagery of the places you want
and to publish it on Google
Maps for everyone to see.
And then for you to use in
your apps and your websites,
and use all the same APIs
that you know and are
familiar with for Street
View, but with photo
spheres and your own content.
And again, why
are we doing this?
It's really just about
helping everybody
have an amazing experience
in the real world.
We want to inspire
you to travel,
to see different places.
This happens to be my
favorite place on the planet,
right there in Hawaii.
And I think that we
have this opportunity
with imagery and with
maps to help people
have better real-world
experiences.
We need your help.
We can't do this all ourselves.
People have unique
approaches to how
they start their experiences
for traveling or for dreaming,
and that's where
you guys come in.
So we welcome you
to use this imagery,
to let us know if we're not
providing the right hooks
and APIs for you to
accomplish what you want.
And I'm really excited to
see what you're going to do.
So thank you very much.
You can learn more about
these products at those URLs.
I'll leave that up for a minute.
And if you want to give
feedback on the talk,
that's the QR code.
And we'll take questions
for five, ten minutes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you want to ask
questions, come up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hey, Evan, I've actually been
a Google Trusted Photographer
since 2012 in the Netherlands.
And that lead actually to me
going into the development
and working with the virtual
tours from Google Maps Business
View.
So I'm the founder of
TourDash, and we really
work with all of the imagery
that the Trusted Photographers
create.
And one of the biggest things
that we run into-- my voice
keeps dropping.
Sorry.
One of biggest things
that we run into
is that the Street
View API is not
as well-supported
on a mobile device
outside of an application.
So if you're looking
at the virtual tours
from within even the
Google Chrome browser
or any of the other
default browsers,
you're really experiencing
a sub-par virtual tour.
EVAN RAPOPORT:
Yeah, we're working
on a better viewer, which
we'll be rolling out soon,
that will work on mobile web.
AUDIENCE: And I can get
that in black-and-white?
[LAUGHTER]
EVAN RAPOPORT: I'll give
you it in full color.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you very much.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Yeah.
LUC VINCENT: Thank you.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Any
other questions?
Otherwise Luc and
I'll hang out here.
LUC VINCENT: We have one more.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Oh, sorry.
I heard an echo.
I was just curious if there
was a hardware issue, or just
a choice why there's only
pictures during the daylight,
or if there's other sensors
intended in the future for--
LUC VINCENT: For
Street View, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LUC VINCENT: So typically
we try to get pictures
when the light is
best, so only daylight.
We have some pictures
of some places at night.
Like we have some Las Vegas,
and some places in New York.
But typically, we don't do that.
Now with the Time Machine
layer, which I talked about,
it is actually possible
to have pictures
at night and during the
day, and to have them
both in the product.
AUDIENCE: So if they're
user-generated at night?
LUC VINCENT: No problem.
Yeah, we want that.
If they are good,
they'll be surfaced.
They'll be prominent.
EVAN RAPOPORT: And
I think there's--
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work for a major
university, and I'm
wondering-- what you've
shown seems to be individuals
publishing photos
as that person.
How would you recommend a major
institution publish interiors
of lots of places, pathways,
that kind of stuff?
What would we do?
EVAN RAPOPORT: So
in fact, I showed
Panedia, which was an agency.
So they're an organization,
not an individual.
So it works just as well for
large organizations using
a Google+ Page identity, and
you could publish that way
if you'd like.
For a university, we of course
have university programs,
where we could bring
a Trekker and things
like that to your university,
or the Google Business View
Photographers, as well.
LUC VINCENT: But they
can do it themselves.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Or you
could do it yourself.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it looks like you're doing
some amazing things right now,
in terms of going down
to the coral reefs,
and then Trekkers
who are taking hikes.
Are there particular areas
of the world that you're now
trying to tackle, or
new unknowns that you're
particularly keen
on venturing into?
LUC VINCENT: I think we want
to go everywhere over time.
And we try to start
with the places that
are the most interesting or
most unique or most remote.
So it's hard to give you
an exact list of places,
but generally, we
want to go everywhere.
And I think that when we have--
so we, all these partners,
conducting trying to borrow the
Trekker for their own collects,
we try to prioritize this based
on what we think we need most,
or areas where we don't have
any imagery, for example.
That's what I would say.
Evan, I think--
EVAN RAPOPORT: And we're
seeing users, photographers,
businesses all over the world
publishing on their own.
So I think when we say
we want to go everywhere,
like, Luc and I would love
to go on all these travels,
and so if you have a
great place, let us know.
But the reality is we can't
go everywhere ourselves,
and so that's why we've
opened up everything to you.
And I'm seeing all of these
amazing spots popping up
on the map, as I
look at our data,
that I just never
even knew about it.
And so that's the
exciting thing, right?
Is seeing that we've enabled
you to go to the places that we
can't.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering
about aerial imagery.
There's a lot of
drones out there
and there's obviously
issues with capturing
the top of the
sphere, whether you're
able to bring in that
imagery and support it.
LUC VINCENT: So we don't
have any drones capturing
imagery right now.
We just have--
AUDIENCE: Right,
but if users wanted
to submit their own
drones, it would
be probably half of a sphere.
LUC VINCENT: Oh, yeah.
EVAN RAPOPORT: So if you put
the Photo Sphere metadata
standard in it--
I've seen, actually,
people hanging like GoPro rigs
from the bottom of a drone.
We have tons of that
imagery already being
published from users on
Views and on Google Maps.
It's just a panorama, right?
It gets published.
So it would work just fine.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
EVAN RAPOPORT: Yeah.
Definitely.
LUC VINCENT: Good idea.
EVAN RAPOPORT: And let
us know if you do it.
I'd love to see it.
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
We'll hang around for
a few more minutes.
And enjoy the rest of your day.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]